european union officials in brussels are
meeting virtually with chinese leaders
for their first summit in two years
high on the agenda is beijing's
perceived neutrality over russia's
invasion of ukraine eu leaders are
likely to seek assurances that china
won't agree to russia's request for arms
supplies and won't help moscow evade
western economic sanctions
well let's get more from our dw
correspondent barbara visa in brussels
barbara
this meeting has been going on where
were there any indications as to which
side beijing supports
um
at today's eu china summit any tendency
you could make out
i mean we heard from chinese diplomats
after the meeting with the chinese prime
minister at the moment the meeting with
president xi himself is underway and
what they said was yeah china doesn't
want to be forced to pick sides so they
don't want to come down on either side
and they don't want to be really
disturbed or questions about the
question about their strategic
relationship with russia so that was
given it was quite clear from the
beginning
of this summit of this virtual summit
that of course there was no prizing away
of russia from the chinese embrace that
would continue it's just a question of
how tight it is now of course
china is trying to sort of play both
ends against the middle here
or if you will right the tiger because
on one hand they want to still continue
the closeness it was at the support for
president putin on the other hand they
do need their biggest trade partner the
european union this is where their where
the economic growth is made and created
and supported so they can't afford a
real a trade war for instance or
sanctions or or real
real problems with the eu and that this
is what china is trying to balance
carefully and and sort of hiding itself
under a lot of diplomatic verbiage
right i mean riding the tiger you say
china state broadcaster cctv quoted the
premier by saying china will push for
peace talks between ukraine and russia
in its own way what could that mean
in its own way that's diplomacy it just
means that yeah we will talk to putin
maybe behind closed doors and we will
tell him you know don't uh sort of
do this in a too brutal manner or maybe
they could find a way to sort of
stop the war and and and have an
off-ramp here within a certain amount of
time they're not going to of course push
put any real pressure on putin plus
putin probably wouldn't listen i mean we
we see this very delicate balance of of
the of the blocks here we see russia on
one hand they need the support of china
because they're still trading with china
and china is now buying for instance
russian oil on the other hand china
needs europe
because that is where the economic
growth comes from but the european union
also needs china and they need china to
acknowledge their security interests so
it's you see those three polls that
really have to sort of figure out how to
balance their interests against each
other and at the moment we have a very
clear message here from europe saying uh
beijing needs to listen to us they need
to acknowledge that this is our security
here in europe we're talking about it's
central and it's crucial to us
and they cannot override our interests
here and we will sort of push against
that and so this is really what what
makes this meeting so important but we
will not have any concrete direct
results this is about politics by
talking
all right well it's better to talk than
not to talk uh thank you barbara wiesel
in brussels
meanwhile eu leaders will urge china not
to support russia in its war in ukraine
at a virtual summit being held on friday
brussels will warn chinese premier xi
jinping that helping moscow to avoid
western sanctions would harm already
strained relations with some of china's
biggest trading partners in 2020 imports
and exports between china and the eu
totaled
586 billion euros representing 16 of the
eu's total trade in goods however
china's trade with one eu member in
particular lithuania has been all but
wiped out is down 91 in recent months
that was after lithuania allowed taiwan
to open a de facto embassy in vilnius
china considers taiwan its own territory
of course but that's not the only thing
straining relations between brussels and
beijing in 2020 they signed a major
agreement on investment however the eu
pushed the pause button last year citing
china's alleged human rights violations
in the xinjiang region so
can anything be achieved during the
latest round of talks between brussels
and beijing well i'm joined in the
studio by our resident china watcher
clifford coonan um clifford a lot's
changed between the eu and china hasn't
it since they signed that investment
deal
yes i mean it's it's like a sea change
basically what you've seen was um i mean
at the time you had the the problem
for the eu that the between the
commission and the parliament that the
commission had wanted to push the deal
particularly from the german side the
germans were very keen to push it
but the parliament was saying no because
of the xinjiang uh situation and also
hong kong
but now
since then the situation has even
become even more tense because of of the
war with um
russia's invasion of ukraine and um
basically now china's backing of ukraine
uh in this situation has made it very
very difficult for them to come up with
the for for the for them to actually
back the deal because they need to put
pressure on china to to
take aside to sort of take the eu side
rather in the war yes so
is it going through the minds of the
government in beijing that you know the
eu is a major trading partner and maybe
if beijing does continue to support
moscow trade relations could suffer and
they could lose a major market
absolutely and i think um you know i
think that basically china has always
viewed the eu
um as a block but also individually and
it's been quite happy to sort of um
to almost you know create a a breach
between the the different members of the
eu divide and conquer divide and conquer
exactly and um there's been a lot of
that going on you know and um
i think that's going to be um
increasingly that's going to be a big
issue now as we've seen with them would
say lithuania for example
yeah actually let's talk about um
lithuania i mean how big is an impact
of an impact is you know there's this
embargo on trade with just one member of
the eu having on relations between
boating and brussels well i think
initially there was uh um the eu tried
to to sort of
calm things down a bit and and uh act as
if it wasn't a major issue but um the
thing is this is a member of the eu
which is being having this as you
mentioned you know this de facto embargo
on on trade and um
also at the same time you've got
sanctions on individual members like
parliamentarians in in the eu so there's
a lot of issues like this which are um
uh very annoying to the eu basically and
they're um and given the fact that china
is backing russia in the war um whereas
before they could maybe try and
negotiate on these angles there's just
too much now for for for everything to
go smoothly there's too many things
going on there's too many breaches in in
the in the dam you know yeah and
actually there's been a concerted effort
from brussels to create a competitor
program for belton road
is that something that's now become a
little more pressing
yeah i think i think that um the eu is
realizing that um there's a german
phrase vandal and handle you know the
idea of change through trade
and they've been pushing that for a long
time i think even the big german firms
are realizing now that this won't work i
mean vw is now investing heavily in the
u.s for example uh there's a lot of
there's a lot there's a kind of a shift
away from china there's a realization
that um you can't sort of separate the
the political stuff from the trade stuff
and i think this is
turning into a a major factor and it's
going to be a big a big factor in these
talks today we've got lee kuch yang has
already spoken xi jinping is coming
later so it's going to be um i mean
these are very high level talks but on
completely different terms and from what
we had a year ago and just lastly
something we should talk about a big
story out of china this week was the
very sudden lockdown in shanghai and
having an impact on businesses in europe
trying to trade with the chinese yeah
the lockdowns are our major thing i mean
volkswagen's have to suspend production
uh it's only for for a few days um but
clearly the idea of china as a as a
reliable source of of of goods in the
supply chain is is now being called into
question um and i think that you're
going to see a lot more um investment in
areas around china in other countries to
to to sort of
bridge this gap in the supply chain and
um
the the whole relationship is changing
okay clifford kunin thank you very much
for staying across the subject for us
let's get some background on this from
daniela schwarzer she's the executive
director of the open society foundations
in europe and eurasia
a group founded by the financier george
soros daniela is it fair to say that the
war in ukraine could mark a tipping
point in eu-china relations perhaps away
from
partnership and towards more rivalry
that is possible if china more openly
sides with russia than it already does
and in fact
you know china has not condemned this
war it has spoken about uh ukraine's
sovereignty that it should be protected
but beyond that
there was really nothing that would show
that beijing uh stands up against uh
this war quite the contrary in february
just before the war started
both putin and
xi jinping met in
beijing
and they issued a rather long statement
which really is a kind of authoritarian
redefinition of the world order and they
kind of um try to redefine democracy as
well and position their respective
countries as the better ones and that
shows you that beyond the conflict there
is a growing alliance between two major
authoritarian regimes in the world and
that has to worry europe
uh the chinese foreign minister uh
warned earlier this week that it would
not be enough to rule that nations are
either friend or foe in this complex
situation what approach can the eu take
here
well the eu needs china in several ways
one is obviously trade and investment
ties and that's a mutual interest
and then there's a second mutual
interest and that is that both the eu
and china and the us of course need to
work together to tackle global problems
climate change and its repercussions is
one of them global pandemics or also
developments in the global south which
will seriously deteriorate because of
russia's war in ukraine food shortages
and the like so there is a real agenda
for them where they should look at
global public goods together but on the
other hand there is a systemic conflict
between the two and that already plays
right into the european union if you
take for instance chinese interference
in eu democracies
also the the regulatory competition
on i.t and tech issues which are
fundamental for the question of
democracy and data protection so that i
think the eu needs to take a approach
which on the one hand protects its own
interests and that is mainly the
dimension of the systemic conflict and
then they have to look at the joint
agenda where they have mutual interest
but it may well be that if china gets
involved in this war uh there will be a
totally new debate and that is on
sanctioning china which will be very
costly for europe compared to the united
states
uh
talk to us about beijing's interests
here in in this conflict why are they
still of supporting putin
beijing pursues a very long-term
strategy and that is really chinese
china's rise to being the number one
world power both on economic and tech
but also in political terms and it's
also trying to change the world order
according to its own ideas it does want
an order but it's just not the western
liberal democratic one and for that
russia can of course be an ally and it
is as we have seen through the statement
that both leaders issued in february
china is interested in russia in terms
of energy provision other resources
and it can also benefit not only from
europe's weakness because this war is of
course challenging and costly but also
in the event of a weak russia china will
know how to exploit that situation i
don't think china has a particular
interest in the concrete conflict russia
against ukraine it's far more looking at
the global landscape and beijing will
surely ask itself how does this new
situation fit into our strategy which is
much more long-term and goes well beyond
that conflict
thank you very much daniela schwarzer
then the executive director of the open
society foundations in europe and
eurasia
thank you